انا ما ما لم اغيره منذ كنت في 17 سنه سن
17 الى اليوم هو اني انتبه الى العداله
الاجتماعيه الى طيار العداله الاجتماعيه
والحريات الانسانيه
الاساسيه عشان ممكن يبقى في مدارس عندها
الحريات معينه اهم من حريه
انا افهم انه في العداله اجتماعيه
والحريات الاساسيه تمام ده ما غيرتوش كنت
في اتجاه القومي الناصري كنت في اتجاه
القومي عربي يعني وبعد كده اتجهت الى
الاشتراكيه واشتراكيه على كذا همم
مذهب او كذا اتجاه وفي الاخر استقريت ما
عندي اشتراكين الثوريين ودي فتره انا
باعتز بها وبافخر بها وباحترمها لان احنا
كنا فعلا نقي وكل اليسار
ولي مين يشهد
دي 13 سنه ثم جئنا اختنا كلنا مع بعض بعد
2000 مع 2013 لانه من 2013 انا بالنسبه لي
كان خلاص اللي انا قراته كله خلص الشعب
المصري الان يكتب شيئا جديدا مش لازم اقول
له قلد التاريخ فعليه ان ارثت لشعبي
واتفاهم واتجاهل معه ويتجادل معه من غير